für den inhalt dieses spots sind alle
parteien verantwortlich
[Musik]
willst du mich doch auf einmal mehr
bewährt
bis heute ist das verfahren der krampus
und nicht ganz auf die acht ist wie zum
beispiel du kommst du dran
die als der fall märz um 18 uhr waren
drei jahre haft betragen
da muss zwei klassen medizin und fast
keiner böse die spd nicht die grüne ich
die linke nicht was die merkel
aber ehrlich gesagt immer du willst
disziplin vollen wartezimmer als ausland
im wartezimmer beim land gibt es gar
keinen arzt mehr
ich bin krank ich hab jetzt fast
absoluter man muss ein bisschen selber
auf sich achten gute ernährung ist ein
arm hoch
sie kann auch ich fand alles selber an
basilikum petersilie cannabis gut führt
aroma gratis aus erding
das ist geil und gut gegen schmerzen
die fdp wolle kontrollierte freigabe und
die grünen
sie wollen lizensierte verkäuferinnen
fdp und grüne wollen
ich glaube ich hab so viel gekifft und
pflege darf so gar nicht denken
du fehlst mir doch nicht leben dürfe
werde oder klar
und die pflegt nicht wenn ich fliege mit
ich bin sowieso viel trinke der fall wie
ein tritt jetzt noch gegen den wählen da
bist du platt bekifft
[Musik]
für den inhalt dieses spots sind alle
parteien verantwortlich
und